bonjour à tous les deux merci beaucoup
d'être en direct avec nous pour ce débat
sur rt france je vais vous demander
d'abord une réaction évidemment à la
polémique concernant jean michel
blanquer requis était un alibi salles le
jour où il annonce un nouveau protocole
sanitaire pour l'école c'était je le
rappelle la veille de la dernière
rentrée scolaire anthony grata cause
qu'en pensez vous
bonjour juste conseiller départemental
pas conseiller régional
et
oui concernant jean michel blanquer ce
qui est terrible c'est que on nous dit
que cette annonce a été faite au dernier
moment pour coller le plus possible à la
réalité
et alors qu'en fait c'était visiblement
un problème d'organisation des vacances
de ministres et dans ces conditions là
c'est quand même compliqué de maintenir
de la confiance envers ce gouvernement
et on voit bien espèce de retour du
bling bling dans la politique française
on l'espère est éloigné depuis la
défaite de nicolas sarkozy mais là et
revient en force et c'est assez
malheureux parce que c'est quand même un
gros manque de respect pour le personnel
enseignant qui manifeste en ce moment
ils ont bien raison de le faire et en
plus je pense qu'ils ressentent ce
mépris de la part de leurs ministres
qu'elle est quel est votre avis
là-dessus et les élèves eléonore baez
excusez moi j'ai du mal à prononcer mon
ce matin
c'est tellement symbolique est
symptomatique de ce gouvernement macro
depuis depuis tant d'années depuis
maintenant cinq ans je crois qu'il
qu'est-ce qui peut encore étonner les
français de la part de ce gouvernement
qui fait la fête à ibiza et je la fait
c'est pas un ibis i-tele tranquille il
est tranquille et au calme pendant que
les enfants eux doivent subir trois
tests par semaine moi je connais des
enfants qui subissent et c'est trés
c'est extrêmement compliqué pendant que
les preuves sont épuisés par des
courants visio des procédures sanitaires
pour l'école en espagne procédures
sanitaires pour l'école depuis bissao
lens des discours sur la france comme
l'avait fait macron depuis l'étranger
quand la ce pays est dans une telle état
de crise on reste on parle aux français
depuis la france voilà et je crois que
c'est très important on emmerde par les
français depuis l'étranger alors le
temps est il venu pour emmanuel macron
selon vous de déclarer sa candidature à
l'élection présidentielle anthony
gratacos on a entendu les personnes
s'exprimer sur cette question
le président qui est de plus en plus
conditionnée en tout cas l évolution de
cette crise sanitaire c'est ce que c'est
ce que dit d'ailleurs son entourage
proche regardez une stratégie à double
tranchant
c'est à double tranchant ça peut aller
très vite dans un sens comme dans
l'autre est-ce que c'est très judicieux
de d'indexer la date de sa candidature à
haut niveau de circulation du virus
selon vous
alors je ne sais pas si c'est judicieux
ça je pourrais pas ça je pourrais pas
vous dire mais je crois clairement que
le président et candidat est d'ailleurs
le pass sanitaire le débat convient
pénible convient d'avoir au parlement en
est la démonstration dans un pays où on
est à plus de 90% vacciner concours de
vaccination faire adopter maintenant le
pass vaccinale qui ne pourrait être
qu'une procédure de plus pour inviter
les gens à se faire vacciner n'a aucune
utilité c'est une mesure purement
électorales pour satisfaire la partie de
la nation qu'il soutient encore
aujourd'hui et qui malgré tout il faut
le reconnaître qu'on joue un sondage
après sondage reste quand même
conséquente
et le président légitimité d'ailleurs
après à se présenter et à présenter son
bilan devant les français mais ce débat
on l'a à chaque élection présidentielle
chaque fois qu'un président à aller à sa
succession il se déclare rarement tôt et
c'est normal puisque c'est compliqué
d'être à la fois candidat et président
de la république est de rester en
fonction
c'est une situation difficile mais
emmanuel mac on s'en sert très bien et
là c'est clairement un plan de
communication sont orages mais j'ai pas
de doute sur le p qui sera candidat
quelles que soient les circonstances
maintenant
on ne sait jamais ce qui peut arriver et
si l'élection 2017 nous a bien prouvé
une chose c'est que tout et n'importe
quel événement peut changer le cours des
choses pour l'élection présidentielle
d'août où cette évolution aussi
incertaine du virus
le pass vaccinale vous l'avez dit
devrait être entrer en vigueur
prochainement est-ce que c'est pas trop
tard finalement de mettre en place ce
post vaccinales puisque la situation
épidémique tend à s'améliorer c'est ce
qu'a dit le président de pfizer hier ils
parlent même d'un retour à la vie
normale au printemps regarder la
question n'est pas de savoir si ce virus
va disparaître ou non ces allons nous
pouvoir reprendre une vie normale et je
le crois nous allons bientôt pouvoir
reprendre une vie normale nous sommes
bien placés pour y parvenir au printemps
grâce à tous les outils à notre
disposition des tests des vaccins très
efficaces même contre omicron il protège
des risques d'hospitalisation et de
décès et les premiers traitements à
prendre à la maison alors une embellie
en vue confirmait aussi par le
professeur fontanes et du conseil
scientifique eléonore baez pourquoi
restreint encore davantage les la
liberté des français qui se passe
vaccinale alors qu on al impression qu
on tend vers l'amélioration les les
français ont du mal à comprendre vous
savez les français sont victimes
vraiment de dinde un président qui
depuis le début d'ailleurs ne les a
jamais écoutés et je crois que son
entrée en candidature ce qu'on disait
tout à l'heure son oncle en candidature
c'est vraiment lorsqu'il a dit j'emmerde
les français c'est ça son entrée en
candidature il au maire des français il
ira jusqu'au bout bon sauf que les
français aujourd'hui ils ont vraiment
vraiment assez du pass vaccinale déjà le
pas salutaire ne s'avère ne servait à
rien et au rassemblement national avec
l'ensemble des députés du sénateur que
nous avons nous sommes tous battus
contre ça le pass à lithaire qui ne sert
à rien parce que quand vous rentrez dans
un métro il ya un monde fou et vous
pouvez attraper attrapé tout ce que vous
voulez dans un restaurant rachat la
voilà maintenant vaccinée avec un schéma
comblé c'est complètement délirant
et ça ne résoudra absolument rien
puisque toute façon ça ne protège pas ça
ne protège pas les autres ça vous
protège vous d'une forme grave c'est un
petit peu quand vous mettez votre
ceinture de sécurité dans la voiture ça
n'empêche pas que les autres vous pouvez
aussi vous pouvez avoir un accident
grave donc c'est quelque chose c'est une
mesure folle et je crois qu'aujourd'hui
en fait emmanuel macron écoute alors oui
peut-être qu'ils écoutent le
certainement le patro confiseurs pour
commander beaucoup de doses et puisqu'il
a dit vacciner vacciner vacciner
vacciner mais encore une fois il faut
quand même se rendre compte que la
vaccination ça reste la liberté de joie
de chacun ça que quand même important et
je veux dire il ya quand même ce que
nantes ou sedan tous cette crise
sanitaire qui a été gérée très mal de
bout en bout eh bien depuis deux ans
maintenant on est là donc alors on parle
là je voyais de traitement kaiser on
avait à marseille décrié ou pas le
professeur out qui proposait depuis le
départ un traitement et qui a soigné et
j'en connais aussi des centaines de
marseillais avec son traitement qu'on a
mis à l'écart comme un paria et puis et
pour n'a même pas écouté en matière de
traitement et plus maintenant alors on
est sur des vaccins des traitements qui
on vous dit qu'au printemps ça va
changer et quid de l'hiver prochain
parce qu'en fait c'est comme la grippe
ça va revenir tous les hivers voilà
c'est ce que dit l'espagne est ce qu'il
faut maintenant penser sérieusement
justement à a rétrogradé cette maladie
dudu coville hongrie selon vous anthony
gratacos est ce qu'il faut suivre le
modèle espagnol
puisque maintenant on a des outils et en
plus
on en est pas encore sorti donc déjà il
faut qu'on sorte de la crise au micro
dans laquelle nous nous trouvons même si
effectivement lissante que ce soit des
croissants mais enfin on a déjà eu
plusieurs mauvaises surprises avec ce
virus mais à priori il semble
effectivement qu'on va devoir vivre avec
son long terme et donc avoir une
approche différente deux virus est ce
que ce sont des approches thérapeutiques
différentes je ne sais pas je ne suis
pas scientifique et je laisse ça aux
professionnels mais en tout cas au
niveau des pouvoirs publics il va
falloir qu'on prenne des mesures
durables peut-être comme on le fait pour
la grippe avec des campagnes
saisonnières
jeu
aujourd'hui je crois que c'est trop tôt
pour qu'on s'en rendre compte
on sent une certaine lassitude pardon
pardonnez-moi de des français les tests
à l'école beaucoup de parents ne veulent
plus en faire pour leurs enfants ils
signent des déclarations
d'enfants négatif alors que c'est pas le
nom ça veut rien les gens ne veulent
plus porter le masque en extérieur on
impose on l'enlève ben voilà il ya quand
même un certain cafouillage et une
certaine lassitude vous ne pensez pas
évidemment qu'on menace et jouent deux
ans les français sont fatigués beaucoup
d'entreprises sont en difficulté les
enfants j'en discutais avec des parents
d'élèves lors d'une visite il ya
quelques jours il y a des enfants qui
n'ont encore jamais vu le visage de
leurs professeurs beaucoup de petits et
de médecins commencent à tirer la
sonnette d'alarmé d'ailleurs sur ce
sujet parce que ça a des conséquences
psychologiques graves on a beaucoup
moins de vie sociale avoir 20 ans
aujourd'hui on peut pas sortir on peut
pas faire la fête c'est quand même
extrêmement compliqué et on l'a tous
subi pendant les fêtes en même temps
c'est une question de responsabilité
collective et on fait bien de prendre
des mesures pour limiter la propagation
de ce virus et éviter qu'on en arrive à
beaucoup plus de morts qu'on en connaît
déjà il faut quand même rappeler qu'au
niveau mondial on parle de plus de 8
millions alors c'est quand même énorme
il y à des épidémies qu'on fait moins de
morts que ça donc on fait bien de
prendre des mesures maintenant c'est
encore tôt pour voir ce qu'on va en
faire mais comme il semble que le virus
est ce que disent plusieurs
scientifiques va vers quelque chose d'
atténuer et d'eau beaucoup moins mortel
mais peut-être qu'il faut adapter aussi
les procédures et les protocoles mais ce
qui est certain c'est que ça peut pas
changer tous les trois jours comme ça a
été fait par exemple à l'éducation
nationale il faut se fixer sur une
méthode il faut voir ce que ça donne de
façon scientifique élaborée et en
démocratie
peut pas continuer avec le conseil
scientifique ou le président prend la
décision dans le secret d'un bureau à
l'elysée ça doit être le cadre d'un
débat démocratique qui prend les
décisions à l'assemblée
justement il ya un conseil un nouveau
conseil de défense jeudi elle est au
north bay c'est ce qu'il faut que le
gouvernement lâche du lest selon vous
c'est évident je veux dire il faut quand
même qu'il entende enfin ça fait cinq
ans que les français entre ligier les
jeunes la crise et cetera les français
lui disent qu'ils n'en peuvent plus il
faut qu'ils arrêtent justement
d'emmerder les français bon alors si les
français leur merde ça tombe bien parce
que dans trois mois ils auront la
possibilité de changer de président pour
une présidente et je rappelle que là il
ya des pays qui lâche largement du lest
encore une fois le vaccin ne protège pas
d'être contaminés ça n'a rien à voir le
vaccin simplement et on vous fait la
troisième dose en vous disant puisque
mois par choix par obligation personnel
j'étais obligé de me faire les trois
heures de schéma vaccinal complet où
vous dis ah non mais on vous met une
toute petite dose on vous a jamais
qu'une toute petite 2 mai dans dix
semaines s'est terminée vous n'êtes plus
protégés quand même savoir ça alors donc
je veux dire les mesures liberticides
depuis deux ans que nous avons de
restriction de circulation nathalie de
confinement couvre-feu en passe à
lithaire est maintenant en basse
vaccinale c'est fini il faut que ça
s'arrête il faut qu emmanuel m'apprend
comprennent qu'ils soient entrés en
campagne ou non et bien que ça va lui
coûter sa place de président 1 parce que
maintenant les gens toute façon n'ont
plus confiance dans ce gouvernement ils
n'ont pas confiance dans les multiples
mensonges qui ont été faits et surtout
est bien la première mesure bon alors
déjà je reviens il ya beaucoup de pays
comme la colombie comme le mexique comme
le canada qui sont en train de lâcher du
lest justement sur ces mesures ces
mesures mais il faut aussi et bien que
le gouvernement comprenne enfin que les
français veulent être libres libres de
leur choix libre de se faire vacciner il
n'y a pas de responsabilité collective
c'est une responsabilité individuelle et
surtout je regrette
individuels comme pour la grippe on peut
pas non plus responsabilité collective y
en a pas tant qu a pas de vaccin ou de
traitements qui permettent quelque chose
d'efficace à 100% là c'est chaud et puis
là je termine super de nessma terminée
et puis surtout s'est réarmé les lits
d'hôpitaux
quand on n'a pas depuis deux ans qu'on
n'a toujours pas où aurait ouvert de
lits d'hôpitaux qu'entend comment quand
on les paie comme dans les dom tom les
soignants qui sont allés en martinique
on les paye toujours pas je dire quand
on sait qu'il ya des gens qui sont en
train de se dévouer à l'hôpital mais
qu'on n'a toujours pas de lire et
animations mais c'est inacceptable donc
je crois qu'au bout d'un moment eh bien
oui il faut lâcher du lest et il faut
enfin enfin réarmer et et refaire et
réarmer l'hôpital et réarmer les
structures hospitalières c'est très
important plutôt que d'empêcher les
français de vivre normalement ses gratte
à quoi je vais réagir
oui alors madame baez a tout à fait
raison sur la question des lits
d'hôpitaux c'est même pire que ça c'est
qu'on a fermé des lits d'hôpitaux des
lits de réanimation depuis le début de
cette crise donc c'est l'été les
[Musique]
scellés condition que le gouvernement a
fait au personnel qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui il démissionne en masse
ce soit les médecins les infirmières ou
les administratifs et qui fait qu'on a
encore perdu des lits d'hôpitaux mais
madame c'est plus rare que ça il ya
quand même eu par exemple dans les
régions grand test des ars ont continué
d'appliquer les mesures de fermetures de
lits alors que la crise avait déjà
commencé donc c'est pas qu'une question
de personnel c'est aussi une question
d'hommes politiques autoritaires qu'on
connaît depuis 20 ans et qu'on a
continué à mettre en place malgré la
crise mais je m'inscris en faux ce que
vous avez et matin madame il est
françois hollande a continué françois
hollande s'est pas toute la gauche
moderne et je suis pas sûr que votre
candidat tu ferais mieux qui veut
supprimer des fonctionnaires et qui
n'annonce rien d'ailleurs en matière
hospitalière ferait mieux que ça mais
sur les vaccins madame je m'inscris en
faux sur ce que vous avez dit se
protéger soi c'est toujours protéger les
autres parce que c'est par exemple
éviter les formes graves et ne pas se
retrouver en réanimation
justement et c'est éviter d'occuper un
lit inutilement pour des personnes qui
sont plus fragiles que soit donc la
vaccination elle a du sens quand elle
permet d'atténuer la maladie et d'éviter
quand même la propagation moi je les ai
vu personnellement pendant les fêtes
j'ai été qu'à contacter à plusieurs
reprises en particulier pendant le
réveillon de noël et sur la dizaine de
personnes que nous étions présents les
deux seules personnes qui ont été
positifs c'est les deux seuls qui
n'avait pas un parcours vaccinale
complet et tous les autres dont deux
personnes âgées n'ont pas attrapé le
kobe de malgré les 6 heures qu'on a
passés à table ensemble donc ça comme
une certaine forme d'efficacité même si
une expérience personnelle n'en fait pas
une vérité universelle je suis d'accord
mais ce genre de témoignage
après les honneurs mais une réaction et
on passe à une autre question j'ai deux
réactions déjà marine le pen puisque oui
à l été en première ligne ainsi que nos
députés et notre sénateur des bouches du
rhône stéphane ravier en première ligne
contre l'alpa sanitaire cotre le pass
vaccinale ça fait plusieurs des mois et
des mois qu'il se passe à l'assemblée
pour faire cesser ces mesures
liberticides et quand vous dites je suis
assez choqué quand vous dites ah bah oui
alors déjà vous dites que le vaccin
empêche la contamination c'est faux vous
demandez à n'importe quel médecin vous
faites vacciner vous pouvez quand même
contaminer les autres mais ensuite vous
dites mais ça empêche d'occuper à
l'hydre elle m'assure mais excusez moi
c'est pas qu'il faut un pc pas qu'il
faut empêcher les gens d'aller occuper
un lit de réanimation c'est qu'il faut
plus de lits de réanimation c'est qu'il
faut un hôpital réel si on a besoin
d'aller en réanimation il sait malgré la
volonté affichée des anges non mais
c'est pas évident il les a manquées
attention c'est pas éviter de danger
vous savez la première chose la médecine
fait soigner les malades c'est ça la
médecine c'est pas d'éviter d'engorger
c'est de soigner les gens c'est d'éviter
que les gens soient malades et je trouve
que cette phrase quand vous êtes malade
il faut éviter d'engorger les hôpitaux
c'est justement cette phrase-là et
aujourd'hui ça a très mal dans l'âme et
il faudra dans la lah des françaises
aujourd'hui c'est extrêmement grave mais
encore une fois c'est votre candidat si
vous avez été en 2010 est
cantonné à tacos à distance il faut
parler chacun son tour alesi des mois
voilà ce que j'ai dit c'est que si la
vaccination permet d'éviter les formes
graves tant mieux ça évite que des gens
se retrouvent en réanimation moi je
trouve assez étonnant madame que vous
souhaitiez à des gens de se retrouver un
tué en réanimation avec toutes les
conséquences que ça a il faut quand même
pas cacher la vérité aux gens c'est
terrible de se retrouver dans un service
de réanimation a pressé pendant des mois
il y a des séquelles donc vous pouvez
pas dire une chose pareille la metiss
justement elle est là pour soigner et
empêcher qu'on en arrive là et la
vaccination permet d'éviter un grand
nombre de formes graves et lise en
réanimation et c'est ça qui est
important dans la vaccination
autant s'il vous plaît il nous reste
vraiment vraiment peu de temps je
voudrais votre réaction gérald darmanin
le ministre de l'intérieur a diffusé une
fausse information sur les sur les
réseaux sociaux il a écrit et dénoncé
samedi des signes nazis lors d'une
manifestation anti pas sanitaire
regardez la photo et puis on va voir
dans la foulée la vidéo dont est issu
cette photo florian philippot
sansan qui a organisé cette
manifestation est évidemment mis
totalement ces signes nazis regardez
cette photo prise en marge de la
manifestation anti place du mouvement
dit les patriotes choque beaucoup à
juste titre à ma demande la préfecture
de police effectué un signalement à la
justice pour que toutes les suites
nécessaires soit apportée
[Musique]
alors voilà et les honneurs baise que
pensez vous de ce tweet du ministre il a
mis les pieds dans le plat
non je pense que le ministre s'embourbe
c'est lamentable c'est lamentable de
diffuser une fausse information comme ça
quand on voit la vidéo ou bien que ça
n'a rien à voir par contre le ca rien à
voir mais par contre le ministre est
bien de s'occuper de ces de ces dealers
qui occupent les réseaux sociaux qui
ceux qui occupent les citer il ferait
bien de s'occuper de ces de tous et de
tous ces gens qui eux en mer de
réellement les français pour reprendre
ses termes voilà quand on voit quand on
voit le nombre parce que c'est bien de
parler aussi du variant microbes et
quand on voit derrière aussi ce qui se
cache derrière et quand on voit tout
s'est tu sais pas les patriotes qui font
du mal en faisant un clapping ce sont
ces innombrables tilleur que je vois
tous les jours qu'ils continuent à
vendre leurs droits au nez de la police
que la justice ne ne condamne pas que le
ministre ne condamne pas en fait il ne
fait rien voilà ce gouvernement ne fait
plus rien sinon qu'un mauvais tweet avec
une mauvaise fait que news donc c'est
dramatique et je crois qu'il est
vraiment temps de changer on t'a des
great aquasud à une réaction et une
reste 30 secondes
oui je crois qu'il faut pas non plus
faire d'angélisme
effectivement c'est pas un salut nazi
mais enfin c'est pas la première fois
qu'un groupe d'extrême droite parce que
c'est bien un groupe d'extrême droite
qui se définissent eux-mêmes comme des
white bloc et qui défilaient derrière
une banderole où il était marqué les
liberté ne s'octroie pas elles se
prennent ce qui est une citation de
charles maurras qui je vous rappel a été
condamné après la deuxième guerre
mondiale et a été emprisonné pour le sa
dénonciation des juifs pendant
l'occupation allemande donc ce ne sont
pas des gens de cigares sont innocents
et c'est très bien l'accusation faust du
ministre de l'intérieur a priori qui
veut diaboliser les les antilles passe
on le voit bien on sait très bien que
des groupes d'extrême droite utilise des
symboles qui a priori n'ont rien de de
très violents mais qui se rapproche du
salut nazi on l'a vu avec la conel
c'est pas la première
pompe à trèves de traduction juridique
et à tout ça mais enfin faut pas faire
dans l'angélisme non plus eléonore vaise
alors très très court et et ce sera
l'après midi il faut pas faire dans
l'angélisme non plus avec avec les
dealers issus de l'immigration qui sur
les réseaux sociaux et je peux vous en
faire un des tweets
ne se cache même plus maintenant de
profiter de l'argent et du trafic du
narcotrafic qui explose ici à marseille
qui explose dans toute la france et je
crois que monsieur darmanin ferai au
mieux s'occuper d'obscurs soi-disant
soi-disant référence à amou race 2 d'un
homme florian philippot qui joue rappel
et de gauche je crois que feriez bien de
jeu fourier bien la gauche voyait déjà
de bons merci voilà c'est la fin de ce
débat malheureusement on n'a plus le
temps on a déjà largement dépassé on y
reviendra merci en tout cas à tous les
deux d'avoir participé à ce débat en
direct sur rt france